[Musique]
une situation chaotique qui a duré au
moins trois heures avec des poubelles
brûlées à travers la ville des
containers
détruits etc donc vraiment une situation
où on avait le sentiment quand même que
les jeunes disposaient du terrain on
avait quand même sentiment d'impunité
pour les métiers qui à leur église
s'attaquer au commissariat de police au
Carrefour Market des Merisiers qui a été
littéralement dévalisé et ainsi qu'à la
poste on enceinte a été fracturé et qui
a également été en partie dévalisé
[Musique]
des groupes de jeunes
quasiment tous les quartiers qui sont
relativement jeunes entre 15 et 20 ans
je dirais d'après ceux que j'ai pu voir
percevoir dans la nuit très déterminé en
découdre avec la volonté vraiment de
s'attaquer au commissariat de police
très mobile très regroupé également et
qui se sont donnés rendez-vous à minuit
pour un coup de feu d'artifice de
mortier d'artifice tenter de tirer les
impressionner les policiers qui étaient
installés au commissariat
[Musique]
des effectifs de police qui
manifestement étant nombre insuffisant
les moyens mis à disposition du
département et du commissariat
d'Élancourt qui chapote notamment la
ville de Trappes n'étaient pas à la
hauteur du nombre des métiers donc cette
diminution des moyens s'est éloignement
du terrain aussi cette distance qui se
crée entre les policiers et la
population et en particulier avec les
jeunes des difficultés aussi liées à des
violences policières qui existent et qui
peuvent créer du ressentiment entre la
population et la police à tout cela crée
un cocktail explosif qui tous les 10 ans
me donne lieu à des émeutes et à chaque
fois on fait mine d'être surpris bien
cette espèce d'ambiance où l'État ne se
préoccupe des quartiers expose et bien
ça aboutit à ce que les gens les plus
confiance en la République
[Musique]